stacy abrams appeared on an episode of
star trek
um
star trek is apparently still
on the air i don't know i don't know
where where it's being uh aired or what
channel it's on but star trek there's
still some sort of series of star trek
out there
and um i haven't watched any star trek
at all but
of course you know it doesn't surprise
me at all to to find out from this clip
that star trek is massively uber woke of
course it is
and in this episode they actually had
stacey abrams guest starring
as president of the united earth now we
know stacey abrams
um thinks that she's the actual governor
of georgia
she thinks she should be president
uh she's there's a lot of hype behind
her nobody can really figure out why no
one's been able to figure out why stacey
abrams is a thing what's what what
exactly is compelling about her there's
nothing interesting about her her resume
is not impressive
she's not even a charismatic
person
when we know barack obama
uh had almost no resume to speak of
before becoming president
but at the very least he was a pretty
good public speaker and he had charisma
and so that's what carried him to the
white house
uh
stacy abrams doesn't have any of that
but
she she believes that she should uh she
should run georgia really run the the
country and if she can't do it in
reality then she'll do it on star trek
so let's watch this scene
we greet the president of united earth
[Music]
madam president madam president welcome
i am so pleased that you've come we are
eager to begin diplomatic discussions
nothing to discuss
united earth is ready right now to
rejoin the federation
and nothing could make me happier than
to say those words
thank you thank you all
what you have accomplished here we were
lucky to have each other ma'am
we couldn't have succeeded otherwise
general
i'm glad to see you recovered
yes i haven't had that close a call in
quite a while i would consider it a
personal favor if that were your last
close call
i never at your service madam president
captain may i have a word of course
uh i'm you know this is the future why
is there not
a polyamorous
trans furry as the united president of
the united world that's my question
stacey abrams is as good
am i even on am i in frame right now for
the camera
just barely okay i'm being told i'm here
we'll just stay here uh
stacy abrams is as good an actress
as she is a politician i'm just watching
that i i it's it to me it's the greatest
mystery in life right now
is why like i get it fred i know you'll
say well right the left has chosen her
as to be their thing because
she's a black female
okay i understand that part of it but
they're like literally any other black
female in the country would at least be
slightly more impressive than than
stacey abrams where you could point you
pick out anybody at random
she's not charismatic
she's not a good public speaker
she has nothing to say obviously
um she's not like physically appealing
she's not she's not an attractive person
she doesn't have that going for either
she's got nothing
and they've just they've settled on her
and they say no it's going to be stacey
abrams it's going to be her because we
insist
[Music]